[Musik]
ein wunderschöner morgen erwartet uns in
unserer kleinen süßen meister fällt
meine lieben freunde wir dürfen gar
nicht lange zeit verlieren ich blende
euch jetzt auch direkt eine time lab
sein denn wichtig ich baue mir heute
nacht und ich brauchte es hoffentlich
auch noch das bild ganz fixiert hatte
ich mir die sachen für die yacht
zusammen suche so freunde ich habe mich
fertig vorbereitet und bewege mich
direkt mal schnell rüber hier vorne und
dafür brauchen wir noch schwarzes glas
da oben ne sache ist
ok ich wollte sagen dass die jacht hier
vorne rein kommt in die einfahrt sag ich
mal
von daher müssen wir da vorne erst mal
ein bisschen sandsteinen weg bauen euch
dafür auch noch eine ganz kurze time
leben schnell
[Musik]
und jetzt starten wir auch schon direkt
denn die acht soll in diese richtung
nach vorne ausgerichtet sein so dass man
von hier halt ganz easy aufsteigen kann
von daher erstmal hier kurz provisorisch
diese beiden blöcke hingesetzt zack zack
zack und diese blöcke kann ich jetzt
auch direkt wieder abbauen
denn das hier wird so ein bisschen das
heißt so ein bisschen jetzt wird halt
der boden von der yacht allerdings
möchte ich dass es hier vorne nicht so
mit einem ganzen block in die richtung
von und zeigt sondern so mit einer
kleinen treppe und dann geht es quasi
von hier direkt weiter zack zack und
dann geht es quasi in diese richtung
hier über 13 blöcke weit soll das gehen
also bis hier vorne dann setzen wir hier
noch einen einzelnen ran die sonne geht
schon wieder unter dementsprechend
platziere ich mal ganz kurz der mine
provisorisches bettchen hier so dass wir
auf unsere kleine stehe ich noch mal
nicht früher starten kann
sehr freuen wenn man minecraft
mittagsschlaf machen könnte dann legst
du dich irgendwann am helllichten tag in
ein bettchen und was dann auch so mitten
in der nacht hier vorne kommen nun 1 2 3
4 5 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 das müssten
eigentlich 13 sein muss ich mal schauen
ob ich mit ihm passiert habe auf jeden
fall kommen hier 13 von diesen quatsch
blöcken dran und hier an die enden dann
hier vorne eine treppe weil das dann so
ein bisschen abgerundeter aussieht und
genau das gleiche auch noch mal hier auf
der anderen seite und nun lassen wir
hier diesen blog frei platzieren
dahinter eine treppe mit einem block und
dann noch mal eine treppe auch mit einem
block dahinter genau das gleiche jetzt
auch auf der anderen seite allerdings
nur einmal denn hier vorne kommt so ein
bisschen das führerhäuschen hin dafür
habe ich mir extra noch eine stein säge
geholt die könnte so ein bisschen wie so
ein lenkrad aussehen ich weiß jemand das
so nennen bei einem boot also mit diesem
ding moment man halt lenkt also mal
summarum ist es dann halt ein lenkrad
und das brauchen wir jetzt nämlich wie
folgt hier vorne eine treppe hin
darunter einen glatten quarz block und
hier auch nochmal eine treppe und dann
haben wir hier den bau wo wir dann quasi
hochgehen können und hier vorne dann das
lenkrad haben also hier die stein säge
hin und diesen raum grenzen wir jetzt ab
mit eisengittern die ich mir gemacht
habe so dass du das ganze hier so ein
bisschen so haben und dann kommt hier
vorne wieder eine reihe quad blöcke vor
allerdings diesmal sogar eine reihe hör
genau auf diese höhe hier und auf die
quarzwerke platzieren wir dann sogar
glatt stufen da kann ich jetzt gar nicht
mehr auftreten
die sache ist allerdings dass ich euch
auch schon mal zeigen kann wofür ich die
schwarzen glasscheiben überhaupt
mitgenommen habe dass ich das ganze
nämlich ein bisschen schnittig aus denn
hier vorne auf diese höhe also hier
12345 kommen fünf glasscheiben und
darunter platz sehen wir nun auch die
glatten fahrzeug und an den letzten
packen wir eine glatte graz treppe so
dass wir das ganze ich hier dann so und
so bauen können hiervon auch noch mal
klassik werke darunter und dann können
wir hier so eine kleine
couch ecke rein platzieren die dann
vielleicht sogar wenn wir das thema eben
ganz kurz machen wir so ein bisschen an
die ecke ran geht dann haben wir nämlich
ist ein bereich zum sitzen und können
dann auch gleich eine laterne dran
machen
deswegen sei auch jetzt schon direkt
denn das hier wird alles überdacht mit
glatten quad stufen und dann haben wir
so einen kleinen schäbigen komisch
ausgesprochen ich packe ich die
vielleicht packe ich die beiden dahin
ich glaube dass er ein bisschen besser
aus dann habe ich noch einen kleinen
bereich wo man halt entspannt sitzen
kann und hier ziehen sich dann halt die
klappe quad stufen drüber und die ziehen
sich generell bis zu der anderen seite
hierüber also einmal hier quasi komplett
so dass wir diesen bereich wo man
spielen kann so ein bisschen überdacht
haben und die treppe die findet sich
dann auch hier vorne wieder dahinter
platziert die glatten quartz blöcke die
wir dann bis hierhin setzen
und wir haben zum glück noch mehr klagte
glock ich dachte schon dann nehmen wir
auch noch mal schnell die schwarzen
glasscheiben und können diese nämlich
genau auch hier vorne hin platzieren da
muss jetzt einmal ganz kurz gucken dass
das genauso ist wie auf der anderen
seite sollte allerdings passen ich würde
allerdings sagen dass wir das sogar hier
so ein bisschen weiter durchziehen denn
wir haben hier den platz so dann können
wir allerdings noch auch hier vorne bei
ihm ganz kurz glatte dings drauf packen
wo er wie machen wir das ich glaube ich
dass hier einfach hier noch eine stufe
drauf und dann hier vorne auch dann
haben es von der seite so ein bisschen
abgeschnitten haben hier den durchgang
und vom wasser ans das ganze land so aus
wir könnten hier sogar auch noch eine
glasscheibe hin packen ich glaube dass
er da nicht gut aus wenn das hier nur so
komisch über die ecken verbunden wäre
wir konzentrieren uns jetzt auf jeden
fall auf das buch heißt es bug und zwar
kommt hier eine treppe dran und hier und
hier vorne kommen auch treppen dran
darunter kommt jedoch blauer trocken
beton wusste nicht dass der so krass
leuchtet allerdings kommt hier
treppenlaufen den sieht man hat er nicht
weil er unter wasser ist und hier vorne
und auch noch ein blauer trocken beton
an dem ich hier hin und hier auch noch
eine treppe so hin und hier zur anderen
seite hin kommen und auch treppen
nämlich einmal höher so nicht einmal so
meinte ich einmal so und hier vorne beim
block ich weiß noch nicht ob sein buch
ist gehen wir einen weiter vorn
platzieren hier vorne die treppe daran
damit so ein bisschen nach vorne geneigt
ist und nun greifen wir zu unserem
blauen trocken beton und geben direkt
mal kurz auf tiefsee kurs und platzieren
den hier vorne mache ich den ja ich
weiss nicht egal ob ich da ich noch mal
auf jeden fall jetzt hier einmal außen
rum den blauen beton beziehungsweise
trocken beton der wta- zu beton wenn man
inhalt unter wasser direkt platziert
also hier einmal auf der einen seite die
nimmt man fast gar nicht wahr
allerdings kann man hier so von der
seite guckt sieht man hier halt das
blaue und ich glaube gerade wenn die
sonne da eventuell einmal krass drauf
scheint nimmt man das auch wirklich war
und ich finde so dieses marineblau oder
dunkelblau hellblau alles alle blau töne
sind einfach verbinde ich einfach mit
der s e und ich finde das passwort zu
einem boot die sache ist allerdings dass
das nicht das einzige an tiefgang jetzt
was wir machen sondern ich hab noch
grauen trocken beton und ich möchte hier
drunter wirklich noch eine weitere ebene
setzen die ich dann einfach hier vorne
so ein bisschen durchziehen und dann
quasi hier der da vorne ein bisschen
zuviel leider die ich dann quasi hier
einmal alle hin platziere so dass man
auch von unten nicht das holz
beziehungsweise das holz halt nicht
irgendwie anfängt zu schimmeln und also
das kann zwar nicht sein in minecraft
allerdings denke ich ja immer ein
bisschen weiter wenn ich irgendwas bauer
also hier vorne dann auch noch das graue
ich weiß nicht wie es von hier aus sieht
das sieht man glaube ich gar nicht ich
weiß auch gar nicht ob er nochmal
wegnehmen sagt vielleicht ein bisschen
schnittig aus wenn wir hier vorne so die
treppen haben und dann da hinten könnte
jedoch fällt mir gerade mal auf ich weiß
noch nicht ob ich noch welche habt ja
genau habe ich sogar hier unten auch
noch treppen dran packen
also ich hier so und hier dann sieht es
vielleicht noch ein bisschen
thaler aus das ganze boot und dann
könnte ich auch ihr nochmal mit diesen
treppen arbeiten also zack zack das
sieht vielleicht sogar noch ein bisschen
besser aus wir können hier vorne
theoretisch auch noch was hin machen ich
weiß nicht wie ich auch noch ein kleines
interne couchen machen viele boote haben
das ja dass man hier noch mal irgendwie
sitzen kann und dann gehts hier
irgendwie so richtig los dann könnte man
theoretisch vorbei und ich glaube ich
bin jetzt ein bisschen zu verspielt soll
ich da mehr an
ich wollte den grat töten aber ich habe
glaube ich genug schwarzen farbstoff
letztes mal gehandelt mit dem village
abu rahma händler typ denn nun kommen
wir allerdings auch schon zum letzten
und auch kompliziertesten teil falls man
überhaupt unkompliziert reden kann
von dem boot denn ich möchte das hier
vorne so nach vorne darüber hängen haben
denn hier passt perfekt und laterne
daran
wir können natürlich nicht mit dem boot
fahren allerdings keine ahnung können
wir das einfach vorstellen
und jetzt müssen wir hier vorne eine
treppe reinsetzen und hier und die
müssen halt gegenüber sein das heißt wie
dass ich da noch mal ganz kurz da hat
und diese treppe muss ich jetzt so
platzieren dass moment noch ein höher
dass sie so steht das passt auf jeden
fall jetzt muss ich hier von der anderen
seite mal eben prozent und einer treppe
platzieren die so steht denn dann kann
ich jetzt hier auf dieser treppe zack
zack setzen und auch von der anderen
seite noch eine quad stufe und dann seht
ihr auch schon gleich wartet dass die
bei ihnen ganz kurz wieder ab
dann seht ihr auch nämlich schon direkt
wenn ich mal aus dem wasser hier hinten
gucken dass das so ein bisschen diese
antenne sein soll dass die bin jetzt
nicht so richtig von mir wenn ich ganz
ehrlich allerdings nicht von weiter weg
punkte kann man das vielleicht erkennen
von daher schaue ich noch mal ganz kurz
ob ich hier irgendwelche blöcke noch hat
liegenlassen unterwasser nähe des
anstandes weg aber dem heute auch nicht
hier muss ich noch ganz kurzen wasser
einmal holen und dann müsst ihr noch mal
gucken ob ich da vielleicht irgendwelche
fässer auf die yacht packe damit wir da
vielleicht ein bisschen stauraum haben
die sache ist allerdings dass ich nicht
genau weiß wofür wir diese yacht
überhaupt gebrauchen werden denn wir
können mit der halt nicht fahren
ich hätte schon bock so für staffel 2
von dem projekt ich war habe ja gesagt
dieses projektes folge 100 also noch ein
paar folgen
und danach kommt irgendwann staffel 2
wenn ich bock drauf habe
ich habe mir schon überlegt ob ich
einige mods installiere und es gibt ja
unter anderem so muss wo man dann sich
mit irgendwelchen vehikeln irgendwelchen
autos motorräder anboten oder so
fortbewegen kann
das wäre eigentlich schon ganz geil wenn
ich das dann eventuell auch mit meiner
yacht machen könnte irgendwie bin ich in
die sieht von hier nicht aus in die
nacht die klingt so ein bisschen unterm
dach
doch man kann erkennen mein gott ich
sollte immer so penibel sein dass jetzt
ein bisschen blöd gelöst mit den teilen
aber ich wollte jetzt nicht noch mal
treppen hin machen aber es gibt schon
ganz nah aus also man kann sich auf
jeden fall vorstellen das ist eine yacht
das also hier nochmal ganz das wasser
ausgleichen
wir wurden in die kommentare geschrieben
luca dotti quad zwischen den sandstein
ja das soll auch so sein dass sollen die
stufen seien quasi dass man nicht durch
den sand laufen muss das sieht schon
sehr geil aus hier was wir für blicke
haben in unserer villa müssen ja auch
endlich mal fertig bauen und hier oben
dann so richtig die einrichtung machen
das kommt auf jeden fall auch demnächst
hier fehlen noch ein bisschen glas ist
habe ich jetzt leider nicht mehr ich hab
nur die schwarzen glasscheiben mit
allerdings schauen uns immer das an was
wir der heutigen folge da wirklich
geschafft haben uns war es das dann
wirklich hier die yacht wenn wir vorne
können wir drauf gehen wir einen kleinen
sitzbereich an dem man so sitzen kann
hinter dem in dem ideen oder wie man das
nennen piloten keine ahnung was dann
kann man sich halt hier anlegen und man
fährt anhalt quasi das hier sollen so
ein bisschen die turbinen auspuffe
darstellen die die dinger hinten heißen
dann gehts hier schnee dich hoch hier
haben wir dann so ein bisschen fenster
sie haben die fenster hier kann man
entspannt sitzen können die fans
vielleicht auch ein tiefer gekonnt aber
sie geld und hier vorn hat man dann auch
noch mal einen kleinen bereich
man könnte es theoretisch auch noch mal
so machen ich habe es allerdings keine
treppen mehr
ist auch egal auf jeden fall vorne dann
spitzt zu und das sieht wunderschön aus
das ist wirklich ich bin so in love mit
all dem was wir in unserer web bisher
schnell warum geht der leuchtturm nicht
an aber gut meine damen und herren a
da geht's an welche durch mein mann
schlagen hier irgendwie kaputt gemacht
und im moment so sitzt an der stelle
welche heutigen episode minecraft mit
lukas oft werden meine lieben freunde
wenn euch meine yacht gefällt und auch
wenn euch die episode gefallen hat das
gern einen daumen hoch und ein video
abonniert main kanal und klickt auf die
glocke wenn ihr neue videos nicht
verpassen wollt wir sehen uns übermorgen
wieder
spannend und wir sehen uns übermorgen
wieder allerdings nicht bei minecraft
sondern bei endlich mal wieder ebay fest
dass die zahlreich gewünscht da könnt
ihr gern einschalten und dann sehen wir
uns dort sonntag um 20 uhr tschüss
[Musik]